ich habe heute mein blick geworfen um
ganz ehrlich zu sein auch mit einiger
energie auf ursula von der leyen es gibt
ja viele gründe sich über ursula von der
leyen aufzuregen als flinten uschi dass
sie die bundeswehr nicht wirklich in den
griff bekommt und auch ihre ersten zwei
jahre die jetzt genau in diesen tagen
abgelaufen sind als eu chefin da fällt
die bilanz auch eher mau aus jetzt hat
sie aber ihrer pannen biografie noch
einen weiteren tiefpunkt hinzugefügt sie
hat eine flugreise gemacht und zwar von
8 sage und schreibe 47 kilometern von
wien nach bratislava das ist etwa so
weit wie von köln nach wuppertal und
dafür die tatsächlichen privatjet
benutzt und damit im grunde alles ad
absurdum geführt was ihr in ihrer
klimapolitik wichtig ist und was sie uns
immer belehrend wissen lässt sie ist
also nicht einfach mit der bahn gefahren
die 47 kilometer wir haben jetzt mal
nachgeguckt es dauert ungefähr eine
stunde und kostet elf euro 20 und das
obwohl sie als eu-präsident in das jahr
2021 zu was erklärt hat zum jahr der
schiene unglaublich und sie hat auch
keine auto benutzt für diese kurze
strecke obwohl sie doch von uns allen
immer zu recht verlangt dass wir alles
tun damit die erderwärmung die 1,5 grad
celsius nicht überschreitet aus meiner
sicht wäre heuchelei und doppelmoral und
deshalb sage ich heute abend so nicht
privat jet ski eine solche präsidentin
kann europa nicht voran bringen
also ganz bemerkenswert für dich ich
meine was denkt sich der frau von der
leyen da also ist das jetzt ihr beitrag
sozusagen zum verzicht auf das auto
benutzen keine straßenverbindung wie
kann man denn ernsthaft auf die idee
kommen also bei einer klimakonferenz
dann mit dem privatjet erstmal zu
starten das ist also nicht vermittelbar
ich glaube das ist das ist wieder so ein
typischer fall von kalender irgendwas
wir müssen da und da hin frau
präsidentin ich glaube auch der staat
macht einen tollen plan und was ich
vermisse ganz oft nicht nur bei ihr ist
das dann derjenige der in der
verantwortung steht sagt wisst ihr was
deshalb der schön geplant aber jetzt
sagt man dem nächsten termin wir machen
das per video konferenz weil ich fahre
jetzt grundsätzlich unter 300 km
entfernung zug
und ich verstehe nicht ihr habt ihr eine
vorstellung warum das nicht gemacht hat
und warum ist dann im sommer
peinlichkeit endet also das verstehe ich
immer absolut nicht warum es in dieser
peinlichkeit endet weil man ja man kann
ja irgendwie bis 1 zählen und annehmen
da passiert irgendwas tragisches weil
das merken ja die leute und ich finde
ich mein ich bin jetzt auch gerade mit
meinem hubschrauber die vier minuten
rübergeflogen
hast du natürlich
fahrt tatsächlich auch mittlerweile
komplett zug ich gucke also gar nicht
mehr nach was die was die inlands
flugverbindungen sind ich sitze auf
sechseinhalb stunden hinzog wenn ich von
ulm nach berlin muss aber ich will mich
jetzt gar nicht thematisiert ich
verstehe es nicht es braucht eine
vorbildfunktion das müssen die haben
wenn man das so positioniert und es ist
ich habe mich mal nachgeguckt also
rechnen wer jetzt schlau ist oder das
thema aus das sind
1130 co2 was sie da in die luft
geschnuppert aus 130 tonnen und also ja
und dann ja hier und das sozusagen
und dann aber immer sagen ja leute ihr
müsst aber das und das machen von euch
wollen wir über das und das ist das
argument ist ja auch immer das gleiche
der kalender es war so eng mit dem
gleichen grund könnte ich aber auch
sagen mir ist es zu anfang ich hatte
leider keine zeit mein müll zu trennen
also wenn alle das gleiche argument
verwenden würden wie politiker ist oft
verwenden dann kämen wir überhaupt nicht
vor also ich glaube das hat auch ganz
stark mit authentizität zu tun wir
erwarten von unseren politikern dass die
sich selbst daran halten was sie
sozusagen propagieren und vor allen
dingen als appell in die gesellschaft
hinein tragen wenn jetzt frau von der
leyen an der stätte gesagt hat dass
dieses jahr auch das jahr der schiene
sein muss dann könnte man ja sozusagen
auch erwarten dass man sich selbst an an
solche äußerungen hält nicht nur
authentizität es kommt auch auf
transparenz an und wir haben ja ein
bisschen ja heute dass wir den gläsernen
abgeordneten haben wollen wir wollen ich
will authentisch zu wollen und die
transparente persönlichkeit ich will
nicht ausschließen dass es fälle gibt wo
man sagen kann ich schaffe das jetzt nur
mit der fahrbereitschaft mit dem
hubschrauber wenn frau kramp-karrenbauer
als verteidigungsminister an schnell
wohin muss habe ich größeres verständnis
ich habe außer es ist die konfirmation
ihre nicht das ist doch so ähnliche
fälle hatten ja auch schon mal aber es
gibt natürlich mit dem programm das man
selber vorgeht werden ähnlichen fall da
was nicht ganz so krass der deutschen
fußball nationalmannschaft die glaube
ich 100 kilometer geflogen stuttgart
basel und stuttgart basel finde ich auch
schlimm aber da ist der vorbild
charakter finde ich doch etwas geringer
also habe eine frau die transformation
ausrufen war aber auch nicht gut auch
nicht auch so in dem moment ihn gewesen
natürlich wird jetzt die welt nicht
retten oder nicht treten ob frau von der
leyen da nun fliegt oder nicht aber am
ende ist es einfach wie will ich es
schaffen als politik an die leute
weiterzugeben hey 7,8 milliarden
menschen reißt euch alle zusammen bei
7,8 milliarden mal wenig gleich viel und
da ist sie ja auch ein teil und deswegen
es geht einfach nicht aus vielleicht
muss man auch an der stelle noch mal
darüber nachdenken inwiefern die
verkehrsinfrastruktur überhaupt
funktionsfähig und verlässlich ist
vielleicht wäre das auch noch mal ein
impuls den mann so zeigen die
europäische staatengemeinschaft und vor
allem jetzt auch an die
koalitionsverhandlungen mitgeben kann es
muss verlässlicher und möglich sein sich
auf die schiene sozusagen zu verlassen
um auch solche termine wahrnehmen zu
können aber es fehlt vor allem fällt
doch zunächst an wirklich der politische
instinkt eines vollblutprofis vor von
der leyen wenn ihre tags agenda
durchgeht und sieht aha flug von 50
kilometern in zwölf minuten in der luft
sagt auch schön freut sich also ein
argument dass sie jetzt genannt hat es
ging dann von bratislava gleich weiter
irgendwie nach riga und es wäre mit zug
irgendwie so nicht zu schaffen gewesen
und alles mögliche mag ja alles sein
trotzdem ist es was vorbildfunktion
angeht schwierig oder
verlangen wir zu viel also sind deshalb
wie man so sagt auch nur menschen und
wir nehmen auch den flieger von hamburg
nach münchen ich weil der zug irgendwie
endlos dauern berichtet kommt aber es
geht also wenn man wirklich dieses thema
für wichtig hält dann kann man sich in
den zug setzen und man kann auch sechs
stunden 30 zug fahren oder auch vier
stunden 30 das geht mit dem flugzeug ist
man nicht viel schneller man muss nur
ständig irgendwas tun weil mal umsteigen
einsteigen aussteigen muss und dann doch
in die stadt fahren ich finde ist
durchaus machbar ich kann da arbeiten
ich kann rausgucken und manche leute
sagen mir hey wenn du jetzt mit dem auto
fährst bist du ja schneller oder
pünktlicher klar bei der bahn gehen
manchmal glaube ich ganze züge verloren
ich weiß nicht was da passiert aber am
ende komme ich doch an mit dem
autoverkehr ist es so da stehe ich im
stau und muss die ganze ich habe keine
frage muss andrea und also hier das weiß
auch jeder
ein navi hat wie oft ist die
ankunftszeit nach korrigiert das ist ja
quasi die die verleugnete verspätung
beim autofahren das legen wir waren ja
viel ankommt man kommt immer zu der zeit
an die das land sagt aber deshalb zehn
oder zwanzigmal nachjustiert dass das
ist dann so ist frau von der leyen
alexander kissler eine gute eu chefin
naja das kann jetzt glaube ich daran
nicht festmachen ich glaube ja wie diese
ist auch viel allgemeiner gemeint mir
ich glaube sie ist keine obwohl kann man
es nicht doch daran festmachen sind es
nicht die ja ich würde es nicht
überbetont weiter instinktlos sie war
nicht authentisch sie waren nicht
transparent es war ein fehler man kann
nicht sagen die transformation ist da
aber mehr ottilien buckel runter das
geht einfach nicht ich würde generell
ihr kein gutes zeugnis als
eu-kommissionspräsident hinaus stellen
es schafft es nicht europa zu einem in
der großen auseinandersetzung mit mit
mit china und den vereinigten staaten
vor allem europa kommt nicht in den
tritt europa hat keine einzige stimme
das verhältnis zum osten europas ist
sehr ungeklärt hat sich auch
verschlechtert und er würde ich sagen
also sie ist keine gute
eu-kommissionspräsident hinein darf
unabhängig dass ich den fehler gemacht
hat ist das konstant
ich glaube sie wurde auch weggelobt kann
man noch nicht sagen merkel hat sich
schon untergebracht auf dem job also
wahrscheinlich selber überrascht denn da
hatte ich mich recht entsinne ist ja gar
nicht angetreten wir haben glück wir
haben irgendwie als andere mal auch eine
absurdität die irgendwie in dem
lebenslauf von ursula von der leyen
wofür sie ausdrücklich nichts kann aber
irgendwie festgetackert ist das ist die
eu
kommissionspräsident in die eigentlich
gar nicht zur wahl stand ich meine es
doch was sagt das eigentlich die bürger
ja das ist sich ein problem aber was
natürlich auch schwer ist weil weil sie
gerade sagen europa ein also das ist mal
unabhängig von welcher person auch immer
die das versuchen will warten sich nicht
schwer also wir haben ja einfach länder
mit so unterschiedlichen auffassungen
also 28 - 1 das ist schon echt ein stück
holz und von daher weiß ich gar nicht ob
es unter diesem aspekt gelingt wirklich
zu sagen hey die oder der macht es
richtig aber ich finde es fehlt ja in
der fähigkeit zu unterschiedlichen
ansprachen sind verschiedene kulturen in
europas die kann man nicht glatt bügeln
das ist richtig aber muss eine
gemeinsame ansprache finden man muss
auch gerade was die osteuropäischen
länder geht ein bewusstsein haben
historisch empfindlichkeiten für
spezielle anforderungen an
demokratische prozesse wenn man im
russen rücken von russland ist das
anders den ärmelkanal hinter sich hat
und da fehlt ihr wirklich das
historische gespür mit verschiedenen
europäischen partnern angemessen
umzugehen und dass ich jetzt in polen
zur persona non grata fast erklärt
worden ist hat sie sich auch selber
sozusagen teilweise